ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen die
Landwirte sind wütend auf die
Bundesregierung und diese Wut ist bei
einigen von ihnen so groß dass sie ihren
Frust an Vizekanzler Robert habck
auslassen mussten der gestern privat
unterwegs war Robert habck wollte
gestern am späten Nachmittag mit einer
Fähre von Hallig Hoge am Anleger im
nordfriesischen schlütsel anlegen eine
aufgebrachte Menge laut Polizei bis zu
300 Personen hatte sich dort versammelt
und hinderte habeg daran an Land zu
gehen laut Polizei versuchten etwa 55
bis 30 Personen auf die Fähre zu
gelangen konnten aber von Beamten auch
unter Einsatz von Pfefferspray
zurückgedrängt werden ja die
Staatsanwaltschaft Flensburg hat ein
Ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet seit
Dezember protestieren Landwirte
Deutschland weit gegen Streichung von
Subventionen für ihre Betriebe und
blockieren dabei beispielsweise auch
stßen wie ihr hier jetzt sehen könnt die
Bundesregierung hatte die Kürzung
gestern teilweise zurückgenommen aber
vielen Landwirten reicht das nicht aus
ab Montag soll weiter demonstriert
werden wir fragen heute gehen die
Landwirte mit ihren Protesten
möglicherweise zu weit was bedeuten die
Streichung der Subventionen für die
Betriebe und worum geht es den
Landwirten darüber spreche ich gleich
mit dem Agrarökonom Professor Thomas
Herzfeld und dem konfliktforscher
Professor Felix andall und ihr kennt
wenn ihr Fragen und Gedanken zum Thema
habt dann könnt ihr die wie immer sehr
gerne mit uns teilen entweder direkt
hier im Chat oder ihr schickt sie uns
per Mail an
zdfhute-live@zdf.de bevor wir jetzt
gleich ausführlicher über die Proteste
sprechen hat mein Kollege Lars bohsack
die Reaktion auf die Aktion von gestern
einmal für euch
zusammengefasst silvester raketen Böller
und verschreckte Einsatzkräfte es war
gestern Abend als rund 100 Landwirte den
Anleger im schleswig-holsteinischen
schlü Ziel blockierten einige versuchten
wohl mit Gewalt auf die Fähre zu kommen
die Polizei setzte Pfefferspray ein die
Fähre mit dem Wirtschaftsminister musste
unverrichteter Dinge wieder auf die
Hallig Hoge zurückkehren die Empörung
ist groß ich habe großes Verständnis
dafür wenn unsere Landwirt und Landwirte
ihre Position einbringen wir haben ja
auch zugehört wir haben unsere Position
korrigiert dafür bin ich sehr dankbar
ich habe davor immer gewarnt aber das
was da passiert das sind Leute denen
geht's nicht um die deutsche
Landwirtschaft die haben vol Träume von
umstürzen und das wird's nicht geben
Kritik kommt aus fast allen Parteien
auch aus der
Opposition ein vollkommen
inakzeptables Verhalten und diese
Chaoten die dort unterwegs waren haben
dem Anliegen dort wirklich ein
Bärendienst erwiesen meine klare
Erwartungshaltung an alle Bäuerinnen und
Bauern aber auch an alle die es mit der
Landwirtschaft halten ist bei den
Aktionen die jetzt folgen Maß und Mitte
einzuhalten Minister habbeck hat
mittlerweile offiziell reagiert
protestieren ist in Deutschland ein
hohes Gut Nötigung und Gewalt zerstören
dieses Gut in Worten wie in Taten
sollten wir dem
entgegentreten auch der Bauernverband
hat die Blockade Aktion kritisiert doch
obwohl die Regierung einen maßgeblichen
Teil der Sparmaßnahmen bei den
Landwirten wieder zurückgenommen hat
kündigt der Verband für nächste Woche
neue Großdemonstrationen
an und mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist
Professor Felix andall er ist
konfliktforscher am Zentrum für
Konfliktforschung an der Philips
Universität in marbu guten Abend grüße
sie guten Abend was haben sie gestern
gedacht als konfliktforscher als sie die
Bilder von gestern abend gesehen haben
ich dachte jetzt materialisiert sich das
was ich schon so ein bisschen
angekündigt hatte
es gibt verschiedene chatgruppen die man
beobachten kann und verschiedene
Zusammenschlüsse die auch schon seit
einiger Zeit im Namen der Landwirtschaft
mobilisieren und das ist enorm viel Wut
im Bauch und viele Aggressionen zudem
mischen sich auch noch andere Themen
in diese Proteste insofern war ich jetzt
nicht super überrascht aber ja da merkt
man da ist schon Dampf im Kessel erleben
wir da möglicherweise gerade eine neue
Form des Protests wie schätzen Sie das
ein eine neue Form des Protests würde
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen ähm
bauernproteste gehen ja weit zurück also
haben eine lange Geschichte und äh man
kann eben mit Traktoren und so weiter
sehr viel ähm Aufmerksamkeit erregen
aber das ist in der ähm Bundesrepublik
ähm so einen großen Aufruhr gibt
ausgehend äh von Bäuerinnen und Bauern
ist schon spektakulär und
außergewöhnlich ähm und muss man auf
jeden Fall drüber sprechen was da wohl
dahinter steckt jetzt hat sich nach den
vorkommenissen von V gestern auch
bundesinnenministerin fäer dazu geäußert
wir haben das Zitat vorlegen und können
da vielleicht einmal zusammen drauf
schauen sie hat gesagt das hat mit
legitimen demokratischen Protest und
harter politischer Auseinandersetzung
nichts mehr zu tun immer mehr verbale
Aufrüstung und Hass führt zu solchen
Grenzüberschreitungen danke an die
Polizei für das
Einschreiten soweit die
bundesinnenministerin jetzt ist heute im
Laufe des Tages immer mehr bekannt
geworden dass dieser Protest oder diese
Aktion die wir gestern gesehen haben
offenbar ja im Laufe des Tages gestern
im Netz organisiert wurde ein Sprecher
von Nancy Feser hat dazu noch ergänzt
und zwar sagte er heute es sei davon
auszugehen dass sich insbesondere
Akteure aus dem rechtsextremistischen
Spektrum wie auch aus dem Spektrum
derjenigen die den Staat delegitimieren
wollen im Verlauf der Protestwoche
versuchen würden Veranstaltungen zu
einigen für einige Interessen zu
instrumentalisieren wir haben dazu auch
schon eine Frage bei Youtube bekommen
die ich gerne an Sie weitergeben würde
für ihre ein ung und zwar fragt jemand
ist das sind das bekannte rechtsradikale
die dazu aufrufen bei den Bauern
Protesten mitzumischen wie schätzen Sie
das
ein ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig zu
differenzieren also es gibt
verschiedenste Gruppen die jetzt
mobilisieren
und viele davon reklamieren für sich für
die Bauern zu sprechen
und das sollten wir nicht so akzeptieren
sondern man muss genau hinschauen wer da
was macht ähm es gibt eine Gruppe und
ich glaube die war jetzt bei diesen
Protesten gestern besonders stark ähm
vertreten ähm die reiten so auf der
Protestwelle und versuchen ihre Agenda
da unterzubringen und diese Agenda ist
tatsächlich gar nicht mehr so stark mit
der Landwirtschaft verbunden sondern die
Landwirtschaft ist wie so ein
Sprungbrett ähm und es nutzen die um
ihre Agenda ähm na vorzuführen und
destruktiv zu wirken ähm es ist
allerdings schon so und das gehört
glaube ich auch zur Wahrheit dass es
innerhalb der ähm Landwirtschaft undter
bäerinnen und Bauern schon sehr lange
Frustration gibt auch Zorn gibt und Wut
ähm das ist keine neue Erscheinung das
ist schon seit Jahren oder sogar
Jahrzehnten ähm weil sie das Gefühl
haben dass sie in der Gesellschaft nicht
äh ausreichend anerkannt werden und
diese Wut kann sich natürlich auf
unterschiedliche Art und Weise
bahnbrechen
ähm und dann gibt's äh Akteure wie der
Bauernverband ähm die organisieren ja
auch Demonstrationen die sind teilweise
auch schon ganz schön massiv ähm aber
dann gibt's andere Akteure da gehört z.B
ähm die Gruppe Landschaft Verbindung die
haben da noch mal eine andere Agenda m
die sind in sich auch divers muss man
sagen aber die sind auf jeden Fall mehr
als die anderen Gruppen aus meiner
Einschätzung nach rechts offen und es
gibt Akteure am rechten Rand ähm die
jetzt diese bauernproteste für ihre
Agenda nutzen jetzt hat sich der
Bauernverband von dem was da gestern
passiert ist heute auch distanziert der
Präsident des Bauernverbandes Joachim
ruckwidk fordert aber weiterhin Zitat
die komplette Rücknahme der angedachten
Kürzung wir können da auch einmal auf
das Zitat gemeinsam schauen und zwar hat
er heute gesagt persönliche Angriffe
Beleidigung Bedrohung Nötigung oder
Gewalt gehen gar nichts bei allem Unmut
respektieren wir selbstverständlich die
Privatsphäre von Politikern ja soweit
der Präsident des Bauernverbandes sie
haben es jetzt gerade schon ein bisschen
angedeutet muss man trotzdem wir sehen
diese Proteste jetzt seit Dezember an
dieser Stelle konstatieren dass die
Proteste möglicherweise radikaler
werden es ist immer schwer zu sagen die
Proteste also ich glaube das sind
verschiedene Proteste
ähm wir haben die großen Mobilisierung
Bauernverband und von einigen anderen
Organisationen wir haben auch äh
Mobilisierung für ökologische ähm
Transformation ähm die wird auch
stattfinden in 10 Tagen in Berlin das
ist auch eine bauerndemo und dann gibt's
diese m Ausschreitungen und kleineren
Gruppen die versuchen ihre Agenda dazu
unterzubringen also es gibt verschiedene
Protestformen und diese Gruppen haben
auch gar nicht unbedingt alle das
gleiche Ziel deswegen finde ich es
wichtig zu differenzieren und auch schon
wichtig dass der Bauernverband da klar
zeigt das geschieht nicht in ihrem Namen
wobei man sagt muss ähm der
Bauernverband hat schon auch sehr stark
zur Polarisierung beigetragen und durch
harte Worte ähm sicherlich auch nicht
befriedet also das muss man sagen da ist
schon zwischen der Bundesregierung und
dem Bauernverband auch ganz schön
konfliktstof da sie haben jetzt die
verschiedenen Protestformen angesprochen
wir bekommen dazu auch beispielsweise
einen Kommentar von Ulli Meer der fragt
wo ist denn der Unterschied zu den
klimaklebern beide blockieren das ist
tatsächlich auch ja ein eine Frage oder
ein ein Gedanke den man z.B auch viel in
den Kommentaren findet wenn man sich bei
uns auf unserem Instagram Account von ZF
heute umschaut zu den Unterschieden und
auch zu den Gemeinsamkeiten haben wir
mal eine Einschätzung vorbereitet und
zwar von unserem Rechtsexperten Jan
henriich aus unserer Redaktion Recht und
Justiz da hören wir einmal rein die
Blockadeaktionen der letzten Generation
wurden von Gerichten in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder als strafbare
Nötigung eingestuft bei der gestrigen
Aktion der Landwirte sieht die Polizei
das zumindest im Anfangsverdacht ähnlich
der Unterschied ist aber dass hier
zusätzlich noch wegen Landfriedensbruch
ermittelt wird und das setzt
normalerweise voraus dass es gerade aus
einer aufgebrachten protestmenge heraus
zu Bedrohungen und Gewalttätigkeiten
kommt ob das hier wirklich der Fall war
das müssen die Ermittlungen allerdings
noch zeigen Herr Professor andall
vielleicht die Frage auch noch mal an
Sie also welche parallelen sehen sie da
tatsächlich zu ja den prozessaktion der
sogenannten letzten Generation
vielleicht auch in dem ECHO den diese
Proteste dass diese Proteste
auslösen also das sind zwei Fragen das
eine ist es gibt eine parallele und zwar
eine Blockade aber wenn wir uns die
Rhetorik anschauen ähm ist es eine ganz
andere also die letzte Generation ähm
hat auch
Straßen blockiert ähm geht den Leuten
tierisch auf die nerven aber sie hat
noch nie jemanden bedroht
ähm und sie redet nicht aggressiv ähm
sie hat keine umsturzfantasien das ist
schon ein ganz anderes Niveau würde ich
sagen also es geht nicht gezielt gegen
Menschen auch nicht gegen Politiker ähm
und das war gestern schon anders ähm ich
sehe in diesen Protesten die wir gestern
gesehen haben aber vereinzelt auch schon
in den letzten Wochen so eine starke
Aggression ähm und wirklich den Wunsch
ähm die Regierung zu stürzen ähm was
interessant ist aus meiner Sicht äh die
sprechköre auch schon bei der großen
Demonstration in Berlin sind teilweise
entkoppelt von der Landwirtschaft
und heißen dann z.B Ampel muss weg Ampel
muss weg das erinnert auch schon ein
bisschen an die Corona prototeste die
wir vor ein paar Jahren gesehen haben da
hieß es dann eben merkel muss weg und
ich würde da auch eine gewisse
Kontinuität sehen nicht unbedingt in den
Personen aber in der Art der Rhetorik in
der Art und Weise wier ähm politische
Inhalte
vorgetragen werden und man kann von der
letzten Generation und halten was man
will aber so eine Art von Aggressionen
haben wir von denen noch nicht gesehen
und ich glaube das macht schon einen
Unterschied jetzt war ja offenbar der
Tropfen der an dieser Stelle das fast
zum Überlaufen gebracht hat bei vielen
Landwirten die angekündigte Kürzung der
Subvention auf den Agrardiesel wenn man
vielleicht den Blick noch mal ein
bisschen weitet also und ihnen auch
zuhört geht es da viel mehr um eine ja
generelle Unzufriedenheit mit der Klima
und der Agrarpolitik der
Bundesregierung ja und ähm in großen
Teilen sicherlich auch zurecht
äh die Bauern jetzt bin ich selber in
die Falle getabppt es gibt verschiedene
Arten von äh landwirtschaftlichen
Betrieben aber viele davon haben
wirtschaftliche Probleme und sind seit
Jahren damit konfrontiert ähm dass sie
nicht genug Einkommen haben dass äh
Preise fallen oder zumindest stark
fluktuieren ähm und dass sie das Gefühl
haben nicht genug Anerkennung zu
bekommen in ihrer in der Gesellschaft
für ihre harte Arbeit und äh das sind
absolut legitime Punkte und ähm das
liegt daran meines aachtens dass sie in
einem System arbeiten ähm das sehr stark
auf eine spezifische Form der
Landwirtschaft zugeschnitten wird äh und
dann europaweit über die EU mit
Subventionen abgesichert ähm und um das
zu ändern müsste man wirklich an dem
System was ändern das Gegenteil ist aber
passiert in den letzten Jahren also
Julia Klöckner hat in ihrer Amtszeit
noch ähm in der EU EU mitverhandelt die
gemeinsame europäische Agrarpolitik wo
für 7 Jahre dieses System wiederum
zementiert wurde und dieses System
bedeutet die Landwirtschaft kann sich
nur finanzieren über Subventionen und
diese
Subventionen werden teilweise als
Almosen empfunden und machen die Bauern
natürlich extrem abhängig vom Staat ich
glaube das spielt eine ganz wichtige
Rolle um zu verstehen woher diese
Frustrationen kommen also ich denke wenn
man wirklich auf die Landwirtschaft
zugehen möchte müsste die
Bundesregierung Pläne entwickeln und
gemeinsam mit Landwirten überlegen wie
können wir denn langfristig dafür sorgen
dass Landwirtschaft wieder ein
attraktiver Beruf ist der sich auch
finanziert der sich rechnet und der das
Ansehen das aus meiner Sicht in der
Gesellschaft durchaus da ist auch
widerspiegelt in den
arbeitsbeleegben Herr andall ich sag
vielen Dank an dieser Stelle
konfliktforscher an der Philips
Universität in in marbur vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit heute abend danke schön danke
schönen Abend wir wollen jetzt noch mal
weiter über die Subvention und auch die
ja die Wichtigkeit der Subvention für
die landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe
sprechen und die Situation der landwir
der Landwirte in Deutschland vorher
schauen wir uns aber einmal an um was es
genau bei diesen Subventionskürzungen
geht und das wichtigste zusammengefasst
hat mein Kollege Christian Semm für
euch im Moment erhalten die Betriebe in
der Forst und Landwirtschaft pro
verbraucht im Liter Diesel
21,48 Cent vom Staat zurück diese
Subvention wollte die Ampel streichen
durch die Kürzung sollte ein Teil des 17
milliardenlchs gestopft werden das durch
das haushaltsurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts entstanden ist
nach den massiven Protesten der
Landwirte soll es jetzt eine wie es
heißt schrittweise Reduzierung der
Begünstigung geben damit sollen die
Betriebe Zeit bekommen sich darauf
einzustellen konkret geplant ist jetzt
dass in diesem Jahr die staatliche
Unterstützung um 40% reduziert wird
2025 dann um weitere 30%. 2026 läuft die
Subvention dann aus und die
Mineralölsteuer wird nicht mehr
zurückerstattet wie hart wird das die
Landwirte Treffen für jeden Hof sein das
mehrere tausend Euro im Jahr sagt der
Bauernverband und aus Halle ist mir
jetzt zugeschaltet der Agrarökonom
Professor Thomas Herzfeld vom Leibnitz
Institut für agrarentwicklung in
Transformation Ökonomien guten Abend
nach Halle guten Abend die
Bundesregierung ist jetzt teilweise
zurückgerudert aus ihrer ihrer
Einschätzung nach richtig
so das war ein
Einknicken was aber an der Natur der
Sache nichts ändert dass die
agrardieselerstattung kein effizientes
politikinstrument war sie hat jetzt was
sie hätte vielleicht schon eher machen
können einfach nur versucht diesen
Ausstieg gleitend zu
gestalten welche Betriebe sind denn von
diesen
subventionsstreichung besonders
betroffen wen trifft das besonders stark
es trifft besonders Betriebe die weite
Wege haben die sehr
dieselintensive Bearbeitungsschritte
machen also viel pflügen und andere
bodenbearbeitungsmaßnahmen vornehmen die
vielleicht auch besonders zersplitterte
Strukturen haben und insgesamt generell
viel Maschinen einsetzen mssen
wir bekommen dazu natürlich auch Fragen
und Kommentare und zwar merkte jemand an
ich bekomme meinen Sprit wenn ich zur
Arbeit fahre oder meine Kraft
Kraftfahrzeugsteuer ja auch nicht
subventioniert warum haben diese
Subventionen in der Landwirtschaft eine
besondere
Rolle die Agrar Diesel Rückerstattung
wurde in der damaligen BRD in den 60er
Jahren eingeführt um die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Landwirtschaft
zu steigern und sicher auch um
Unterschiede in innerhalb der
Europäischen Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft der
damaligen
auszugleichen dahinter steht ein ein
Bild was über viele Jahrzehnte die
Politik dominiert hat dass die
Landwirtschaft eine besonderstellung hat
also die Landwirtschaft weil sie eben
Nahrungsmittel produziert und für unsere
Ernährung so essentiell wichtig ist und
über 50% der Fläche in Deutschland durch
ihre Nutzung
prägt eben nicht gleich zu behandeln ist
mit einem normalen Hand wksbetrieb oder
anderen Selbständigen Unternehmen und
dieses Bild hat sich eben sehr stark
festgesetzt und dominiert eben auch
viele Aussagen die wir jetzt von den
Interessenvertretern
hören lassen sich diese diese
Zusatzkosten die eben für die Betriebe
entstehen durch den Wegfall der
Subventionen lässt sich das irgendwie
quantifizieren was da tatsächlich dann
an ja mehr Kosten auf die Betriebe
zukommt das hängt sehr stark von der aus
Richtung der Betriebe ab ein Betrieb der
sehr sehr wenig Flächen bewirtschaftet
viel z.B Schweinemast betreibt oder
legerändenhaltung betreibt ist davon
natürlich deutlich weniger betroffen als
ein spezialisierter ackerbauetrieb der
nur Ackerbau betreibt also nur Pflanzen
anbaut und viel auf dem mit Maschinen
arbeiten muss es sind pro für ein 100
Hektar Betrieb
[Musik]
mal im Durchschnitt gerechnet sind es je
nach aus Richtung zwischen 2000 3000
4000 € pro Jahr die
das
ausmachen okay für wie viele Betriebe
sind denn wenn ich es jetzt mal ein
bisschen salop formulieren darf diese
Subventionen nice to have und bei
welchen Betrieben geht es da tatsächlich
dann auch ums wirtschaftliche Überleben
wenn wir auf diese Subventionen schauen
genau quantifizieren kann ich das leider
nicht aber es ist denke ich immer
wichtig zu betonen dass der Anteil
dieser
agrardieselrückerstattung an den
gesamten Subventionen die ein
landwirtschaftlicher Betrieb erhält nur
relativ klein ist wir reden hier über 8
9 10 vielleicht maximal 12% der
Subventionen und Zuschüsse die ein
Betrieb erhält sind kommen über die
agrieselrückerstattung der viel größere
Bereich kommt über die Direktzahlung im
Rahmen der europäischen Agrarpolitik die
im Moment überhaupt nicht angefasst
werden
soll welche ja welche Perspektive sehen
sie dass sich daran etwas
ändert meinen Sie jetzt die
Direktzahlung oder meinen Sie dass die
Betriebe manche Betriebe Probleme haben
genau also dass sich sozusagen die die
Bauern weisen jetzt ja in den
vergangenen Wochen immer wieder auf ihre
Probleme und ihre Situation hin haben
Sie das Gefühl dass das sozusagen von
politischen Entscheidern die Ampel
diskutiert ja viel drüber in Teilen auch
auch öffentlich dass das sozusagen
gesehen wird und da dann perspektivisch
im Sinne der Bauern auch ja etwas
verändert
wird da haben wir wieder das
Grundproblem was auch Herr anders ander
angesprochen
hat wenn wir akzeptieren dass wir ein
marktwirtschaftliches System haben dann
argumentiere ich als Wirtschafts also
Agrarökonom oder aus
wirtschaftswissenschaftlicher Sicht
immer dass es dazu gehört dass Betriebe
die nicht am Markt ihre Erträge
erwirtschaften können auch aus dem Markt
ausscheiden müssen und andere Betriebe
die wettbewerbsfähiger sind am Markt
bestehen bleiben können das haben wir in
der Landwirtschaft so nicht ja wir haben
eine sehr starke Unterstützung durch
Subventionen und
Zuschüsse aber dieses Grundidee dieser
Grundkonflikt besteht natürlich und der
lässt sich durch politische Maßnahmen
nie komplett
aufheben eine Frage die wir auch bei
YouTube bekommen haben und zwar von
ähm ohne Namen aber kann ein inwiefern
können Betriebe denn tatsächlich vom
Diesel auf Alternativen umstellen also
ja wie viel Alternativen gibt es zu
diesem
Diesel das ist natürlich ein großes
Problem die Maschinen sind sehr schwer
und es gibt im Moment keine alternativen
Antriebe über Elektromotoren oder
ähnliches
ähm deswegen sind die Landwirte auf den
Diesel angewiesen sie könnten eventuell
im kleinen Rahmen z.B auf
bodenbearbeitungsschritte verzichten
also nicht mehr flugl mit dem Flug
arbeiten sondern nur noch fluglos
arbeiten was sicher weniger Sprit
verbrauchen würde oder Arbeitsgänge
kombinieren aber Betriebe die sehr
effizient arbeiten nutzen diese
Möglichkeiten schon meistens aus und
haben da wenig Spielraum noch weiter
einzusparen vielleicht noch mal gefragt
nach den politischen Maßnahmen und zwar
haben wir von Michael sarembe eine Frage
bekommen die Bauern haben sehr häufig
den Eindruck für vieles als Sündenböcke
herhalten zu müssen was kann denn
politisch getan werden um den Bauern
mehr Wertschätzung
entgegenzubringen die Landwirtschaft
leistet sehr viel und bringt sehr viele
was wir als Ökonom als öffentlich Güter
bezeichnen ja wir sprechen über den
zunehmenden Anspruch den
treibhaostgasemission zu reduzieren und
hier spielt gerade die
Kohlenstoffbindung in Pflanzen im Boden
in Form von Humus oder durch fost durch
Bäume und Gehölze eine sehr sehr
wichtige Rolle und hier wird ein dies
Erreichen des Ziels der Klimaneutralität
ohne die Landwirtschaft gar nicht
funktionieren gleiches gilt für z.B
aktuelles Beispiel den Hochwasserschutz
wenn Ausgleichsflächen zur Verfügung
gestellt werden sollen die notfalls
geflutet werden können dann geht das nur
mit der Landwirtschaft und hier wäre es
möglicherweise ein Weg diese
öffentlichen Güter die die
Landwirtschaft
bereitstellt stärker zu honorieren und
auch gezielter zu fördern und auch im in
der Diskussion stärker zu betonen aber
eben nicht mit pauschalen Subventionen
schon abzudecken jetzt sind ja viele
politische Maßnahmen eben auch oft
sozusagen ja an in einer an die
Bundesregierung einer bestimmten
Legislaturperiode gebunden für die die
Landwirte wenn es darum geht in Ihre
Zukunft zu investieren dann reden wir
häufig von Investitionen die dann die
nächsten 20 30 oder 40 Jahre in den
Blick nehmen welche Möglichkeiten sehen
Sie dieses Grundproblem was ja ganz
offenkundig immer wieder für großen
Frust sorgt möglicherweise
aufzulösen das ist sehr sehr richtig die
politischen Zyklen unterscheiden sich
von Investitionszyklen in einem
landwirtschaftlichen
Unternehmen das auch das wird
sich nicht so einfach lösen können eine
Möglichkeit wäre dass es verbindliche
Abmachungen gibt an die sich auch
folgeereierungen halten gerade die
Agrardiesel Rückerstattung auch die KFZ
Steuerbefreiung sind ja Instrumente die
über mehrere
Legislaturperioden dauerhaft
eingehalten wurden oder fortgesetzt
wurden hier hat keine Bundesregierung
oder nur mag nah mal Änderung
vorgenommen
wenn es auch im Gegenzug äh solche so
ein Konsens gebe dass die
Kohlenstoffbindung z.B
längerfristig honoriert wird oder das
tierwohlstandards
längerfristig Bestand haben und nicht
immer weiter geändert werden dann müsste
das Vertrauen sozusagen auf der anderen
Seite auch geschaffen werden dass hier
äh eine ja ein gütliches Zusammenarbeit
möglich ist sagt Professor Thomas
Herzfeld vom Leibnitz Institut für
agrarentwicklung in
transformationsökonomien vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit und für die Einschätzung heute
abend dan schön ja soweit unser ZDF
heute live zu den aktuellen Protesten
und Forderung der Landwirte in
Deutschland mehr Infos mehr Infos und
aktuelle Entwicklung z.B zu den Demos ab
der kommenden Woche findet ihr wie immer
in unserer ZDF heute App danke fürs
zuschauen und ein schönes Wochenende
euch
ه